well I do want to welcome you to the
2018 g3 conference and this special pre
conference debate addressing global
warming just kidding it's the only
levity that we'll have all night I'm
sure my name is Michael O'Fallon and I
am the founder and editor of sovereign
nations
it's an organization committed to the
rights of sovereign nations in the faith
that stands as the bedrock foundation of
Western civilization tonight we come
together to do what so many seemingly
can't do in other arenas of disagreement
and politic politics and that is to
debate to argue one position and truth
claim against another and yet to do so
with respect for our fellow man with us
tonight our what I believe to be the
best two representatives of both
Christian and Muslim apologetics I
personally selected each participant for
their ability to both represent their
own position with strength while at the
same time being careful to not
misrepresent the opposite side or engage
in ad hominem argument ation my job is
to simply and fairly moderate without
any biased interference the men with me
tonight completely disagree with one
another in regards to the following
question do we need the cross for
salvation representing the Islamic side
of this question is a gentleman that we
have brought all the way from Pakistan
to be in warm Atlanta Georgia this
evening would you please welcome Adnan
Rashid
and representing the Christian side of
this argumentation will be dr. James
white from Phoenix Arizona
[Applause]
tonight we will follow a modified
lincoln-douglas format the opening
statements will be 20 minutes followed
by 10 minutes of rebuttal then we will
have 4 10-minute sessions of
cross-examination where one man can only
ask questions and one man can only
answer questions we will then have 10
minutes apiece for clothes and then
we'll be handling some audience
questions after the rebuttal period we
will have a brief 5-minute break and as
well we would ask that you find some
paper and submit some questions up to
the front desk here the moderator stand
during that time so if you just give me
one minute I'm gonna head down to the
moderators table dr. white will come up
and take the podium and start with his
opening presentation Mike I need the
paper thank you I'm sorry I prepared his
arguments for him before so thank you
very much it is indeed and honored to be
with you here this evening our subject
is one that should interest every person
in this audience whether you come from a
Christian or a Muslim background or
maybe even no religious background
whatsoever because the fact that it
separates two of the world's major
religions on an extremely important
issue both Christianity and Islam
acknowledged the historical reality of
the person of Jesus the Messiah but we
have very different beliefs as to who he
was and specifically what he
accomplished this evening our focus is
upon soteriology upon the doctrine of
salvation and specifically Christ's
redemptive work we disagree about who he
was Christians believe he was the son of
God the very incarnate second person of
the Trinity Muslims of course do not
believe this but while that is relevant
to our debate this evening we are going
to be focusing specifically upon
the Christian belief that the cross is
necessary for salvation is the cross
necessary for salvation for the
Christian people the cross is the center
point of history the jewel of the triune
God's eternal intention to demonstrate
his glory in the gracious free and
perfect redemption of an undeserving
people in Islamic theology the cross has
no redemptive meaning Jesus did not die
upon the cross was not crucified and
hence did not rise again there is no
need for substitutionary atonement in
Islamic theology the Christian view of
Christ is considered excess in the Quran
and Muslims often speak of the worship
of the Cross as kufur an act of unbelief
or even worse shirk an act of idolatry
now either the cross is the greatest
redemptive act of the Creator that by
its very audacious 'no saul other
salvific claims irrelevant and empty or
it is a tremendous sleight and insult to
God by its very nature it precludes any
kind of middle ground it has to be one
or the other so for our debate this
evening in the very brief time that I
have I must demonstrate the centrality
of the cross in divine revelation we
will begin with the writings of Jesus's
apostles secondly I will trace this
truth from its prophetic underpinnings
in the writings of the ancient prophets
of what we call the Old Testament or the
Tanakh and finally we will consider the
necessary nature of this great work of
redemptive love so let us turn to what
the scriptures say as a foundation first
and foremost in Acts chapter 2 we read
Peter saying men of israel listen these
words jesus the nazarene a man attested
to by god with miracles and wonders and
signs which God performed through him in
your midst just as you yourselves know
this man delivered over by the
predetermined plan and foreknowledge of
God you nailed to a cross by the hands
of godless men and put him to death but
God raised him up again putting an end
to the agony of death since it was
impossible him to be held in its power
the central aspect of the
proclaimation here at the earliest
period of the Apostles is the cross the
redemptive act of God in Jesus Christ
later on in Acts chapter 4 rulers and
elders the people if we are on trial
today for a benefit done to a sick man
as to how this man has been made well
let it be known to all of you and to all
the people of Israel that by the name of
jesus christ the nazarene whom you
crucified whom God raised from the dead
by this name this man stands here before
you in good health even in the working
of miracles in the healing of the sick
man it's Jesus Christ and him crucified
and risen from the dead that is central
to the Christian Proclamation in 1st
Corinthians chapter 1 we read for Christ
did not send me to baptize but to preach
the gospel not in cleverness of speech
so that the cross of Christ would not be
made useless for the message of the
Cross is foolishness to those who are
perishing but to us who are being saved
it is the power of God and only a few
words later for indeed Jews asked for
signs and Greeks search for wisdom but
we preach Christ crucified to Jews a
stumbling block into Gentiles
foolishness but to those who are the
called both Jews and Greeks Christ the
power of God and the wisdom of God you
can tell that in this proclamation of
the gospel the cross and the salva quirk
of Christ absolutely central in this
earliest period of the Christian faith
Paul later says in that same epistle for
I determined to know nothing among you
except Jesus Christ and him crucified
but we speak God's wisdom the mystery
the hidden wisdom from which God
predestined before the ages to our glory
the wisdom which none of the rulers this
age has understood for if they had
understood it they would not have
crucified the Lord of glory the glorious
Lord was crucified this is central to
the Christian Proclamation when Paul
wrote to the church Ephesus he said for
he himself is our peace who made both
groups into one and broke down the
barrier of the dividing wall how did he
do this by abolishing in his flesh the
enmity how do you bring Jews and
Gentiles together into one body
cross of Jesus Christ which is the law
of Commandments contained in ordinances
so it in himself he might make the two
into one new man thus establishing peace
and might reconcile them both in one
body to God through the cross by it
having put to death the enmity and when
he wrote to the Colossians he likewise
said for it was the father's good
pleasure for all the fullness to dwell
in him and through him to reconcile all
things to himself how having made peace
through the blood of his cross he was
prophesied to be the Prince of Peace
how does he bring about that peace
through the blood of his cross through
him I say whether things on earth or
things in heaven the Cross has cosmic
significance in the earliest Christian
writings in that same epistle Paul said
when you were dead in your
transgressions and the uncircumcision of
your flesh he made you alive together
with him having forgiven us all our
transgressions having canceled out the
certificate of debt consisting of
decrees against us which was hostile to
us and he has taken it out of the way
having nailed it to the cross the very
reason that Christians can believe that
they have peace with God is focused upon
that center point of history where the
god man gives his life voluntarily upon
the cross of Calvary in the book of
Hebrews likewise therefore since we have
so great a cloud of witnesses
surrounding us let us also lay aside
every encumbrance and the sin which so
easily entangles us and let us run with
endurance the race that is set before us
fixing our eyes on Jesus the author and
perfecter of faith who for the joy set
before him endured the cross despising
the shame and has sat down at the right
hand of the throne of God again the
cross at the very core the very center
not only of how we have peace with God
but likewise how we as Christians are to
live the Christian life the model that
we are to have is to have our eyes
focused upon Jesus Christ so the New
Testament witness cannot be questioned
the cross is absolutely central but is
that some innovation is it in excess
it go beyond the prophetic word well the
Lord Jesus taught his disciples after
his resurrection Luke 24:44 that all
things which are written about me in the
law of Moses and the prophets and the
Psalms must be fulfilled this is a key
element of the New Testament teaching
and in that process one of the texts
that clearly he directed people to was
Psalm 22 he directed us to Psalm 22 is
some of his own dying words on the cross
you are probably familiar with the words
as they come across an Aramaic Eloi Eloi
Lama sabachthani in Hebrew Ailee Ailee
lama sabachthani my god my god why have
you forsaken me now as Jesus is hanging
upon the cross this is not as this often
misunderstood some idea that that oh
he's been abandoned by God and and and
there's that there's he senses failure
here or something like that he is
specifically quoting a phrase that
everyone would have would have
understood it would be like me saying
Amazing Grace how sweet the sound I
don't have to continue on from there
because pretty much everyone in this
room knows the rest of that particular
hymn will Psalm 22 is one of the songs
of the people of God and so Jesus is
directing us to the 22nd Psalm he's
directing us to it well when we go to
the 22nd Psalm what do we find all who
see me sneer at me they separate with
the lip they wagged the head saying
commit yourself to Yahweh let him
deliver him let him rescue him because
he delights in him this is exactly what
the Messiah is experiencing on the cross
this is exactly what is happening round
about him I am poured out like water and
all my bones are out of joint my heart
is like wax it is melted within me my
strength is dried up like a potsherd and
my tongue Cleaves to my jaws and you lay
me in the dust of death and then one of
the key texts for dogs have surrounded
me a band of evildoers has encompassed
me they pierced my hands and my feet now
why do I have that graphic of some
ancient Hebrew fragments up there well
if we need to we can get into whether it
is like a lion or they pierced my hand
in my feet there is dispute about that
the greek septuagint
and certain Masoretic text say they
pierced my hands and my feet others say
like a lion
it's a textual variant we can get into
it if we need to maybe we won't we'll
see but definitely we'll be able to do
so if the need arises but just consider
this text as a whole and you'll see it
is being fulfilled in what takes place
at Calvary it continues on to say I can
count all my bones they look they stare
at me they divide my garments among them
and for my clothing they cast lots this
is the description of what the Lord
Jesus himself experienced upon the cross
of Calvary at the end of Psalm 22
posterity will serve Him it would be
told to the Lord the coming generation
they will come and will declare his
righteousness to a people who will be
born that he has performed it the point
here is very clear Psalm 22 ends with
the vindication of the suffering servant
and this is what Jesus intends us to see
on the cross when he cries out Eloi Eloi
Lama sabachthani he points us to Psalm
22 and we see the consistency between
what is said in Psalm 22 and the
fulfillment in the new testament
scriptures that i've already read in
your hearing here we have the famous
isaiah scroll from Qumran and this is
the very section where we find what is
today known as Isaiah chapter 53 surely
our griefs he himself bore and our
sorrows he carried yet we ourselves
esteemed him stricken smitten of God and
afflicted but he was pierced through for
what for our transgressions he was
crushed for our iniquities the
chastening for our well-being fell upon
him and by his scourging we are healed
we have substitutionary suffering taking
place here written 700 years before the
events in Christ's life that graphic I
show you has written 100 years before
Christ was born all of us like sheep
have gone astray each of us has turned
to his
own way but Yahweh has caused the
iniquity of us all to fall on him this
is substitution in his suffering he was
oppressed and he was afflicted yet he
did not open his mouth like a lamb that
has led to slaughter and like a sheep
that is silent before it's Shearer's so
he did not open his mouth by oppression
and judgment he was taken away and as
for his generation who considered that
he was cut off by the land of the living
for the transgression of my people to
whom the stroke was due but Yahweh was
pleased to crush him putting him to
grief if he would render himself as a
guilt offering
he will see his offspring and my friends
I stopped just to say look around the
room 2,000 years later he will see his
offspring here we are speaking a
different language and we follow him he
will see his offspring he will prolong
his days and the good pleasure of Yahweh
will prosper in his hand as a result of
the anguish of his soul he will see it
and be satisfied by his knowledge the
righteous one my servant will do what
will justify the many why as he will
bear their iniquities almost sounds like
it's coming straight out of Romans 3 and
for the gospel seven hundred years
before Christ therefore I will allot him
a portion with the great he will divide
the booty with the strong because he
poured out himself to death and was
numbered with the transgressors yet he
himself bore the sin of many and
interceded for the transgressors I don't
have time to get into the fulfillment of
this in the book of Hebrews and Christ's
role as our high priest and all these
other beautiful things but here you have
the very voice of prophecy the
consistency so let's consider these
things together God is holy just pure
and cannot abide that which is evil and
impure in his presence God announced his
redemptive purpose as far back as
genesis 3:15 we don't have time we could
I could not even list the prophetic
passages relevant to the Ministry of
Jesus Christ in the time that is
allotted to me but we've looked at two
very clear one
but they are not the only ones the state
of man having fallen in Adam this is one
of the areas of disagreement the state
of man having fallen in Adam required a
radically powerful redemptive act of God
the law pointed toward a greater
fulfillment imagine that High Priest
every time he comes in and he sprinkles
the blood upon the mercy seat there's
still blood there from the last time and
he's going to have to do it again the
next year and the next year that
repetitive action was meant to point
toward a greater fulfillment every
person who functioned in within the
context that law if they would but look
could see that greater fulfillment that
would be coming the cross is the
ultimate display of all of God's
attributes he sovereignly orchestrates
its time and its place it took place
exactly when God decreed that it would
take place it shows his holiness it
shows his wrath against sin I have said
many times if when you look at the cross
all you see is love you're not seeing
all the cross because the love that is
seen there is seen more deeply and
properly against the background of God's
wrath against sin His Holiness stands in
the background the nature of the one
giving himself the very God man shows
his condescension his love remember
earlier the Lord of glory they would not
have crucified the Lord of glory the
glorious Lord His sufferings demonstrate
his deep mercy and his compassion for
sinners he could have called a whole
Legion of angels but he does not do so
he restrains that power in grace and
mercy the cross fulfills God's law which
is a reflection of his very nature and
this is another area we're gonna have to
discuss because we believe it is
absolutely vital that God's law be
fulfilled either his wrath must must
come against sin or there must be
propitiating you can't just simply wink
at sin you can't just simply say I
forgive sin without the law being
made right this is a major difference
this evening without atonement the law
remains broken and violated God's glory
marred and as a result forgiveness
becomes arbitrary in God's part a noble
on our part and uncertain in our
experience only in the cross do we find
God's holiness justice wrath love
compassion mercy and grace fulfilled in
one cosmic moment of prophetic
fulfillment it is truly the center point
of history everything before it pointed
to it everything since exists in the
light of it and points back to that
center point of history itself so why
was the cross necessary because God
eternally ordained it as the means of
his own self glorification eternally
it's part of God's decree God prophesied
the cross and in the self giving
Ministry of the south-south of the
suffering servant in Isaiah 53 700 years
earlier
God's entire purpose to graciously join
a people to himself through the son
providing for them full and free
redemption from sin in his voluntarily
taking their punishment upon himself
that act requires their purchase by this
one central redeeming act of Father Son
and spirit all who were involved in the
cross and in the resurrection and so as
a result we looked at the book of
Revelation and the book of Revelation
points us toward the future in
fulfillment and gives us a vision of
what it's like in heaven
the continuous worship of God that takes
place there how its undisrupted by what
takes place here upon this earth man may
rage but God remains absolutely
sovereign over his universe and there
were given a vision once the Lamb has
come forward the Lamb who
Shlain you have the elders and you have
myriads of angels and they're
worshipping God and we are told in
Revelation chapter 5 and they sang a new
song saying to the lamb worthy are you
to take the book and to break its seals
for you were slain and purchased for God
with your blood men from every tribe and
tongue and people and nation you have
made them to be a kingdom and priests to
our God and they will reign upon the
earth is the cross necessary for
salvation if there is an empty tomb
there is your proof because God raised
him from the dead this was the central
core of the message of Jesus's disciples
this is the Christian teaching and we
thank you this evening for being here to
listen to this very important discussion
thank you very much thank you dr. white
and now with his opening presentation if
you can give us just a moment as we
switch VGA cables Adnan Rashid right
before you start the time thank you for
inviting me to America to have this
debate I'm always very pleased to debate
dr. James white I have a lot of respect
for him I've told him this many times so
I'm not going to waste time telling him
any more of that I always exchange
presents with dr. James white every time
we debate it seems this time he doesn't
have one for me
unless you pulled something out of your
bag but I always like to give presents
to dr. James white because I know he's a
dedicated Christian and I have a large
collection of books on Christianity this
particular one is an interesting one
it's a New Testament in Latin published
in 1697 and interpreted by a theodore
beza who was also a Calvinist so are
talking of her friendship to dr. James
white very much and I do have things for
you later and start my time now right in
the name of God the merciful the
beneficent I am Adnan Rashid I'm from
London this time I traveled from
Pakistan to debate dr. James White and
the topic today is do we need the cross
for salvation very very interesting
topic dr. James white preached a very
passionate sermon and if I didn't know
what I know today and listen to dr.
James white I would have been ready to
baptize myself but unfortunately that's
not going to happen because I have this
to present what follows what James will
have to show us tonight
salvation cannot be achieved without the
cross and teachings of the Old Testament
and the New Testament on salvation
through works / repentance or the law
are erroneous and/or abrogated Jesus not
Paul was responsible for teaching
salvation through the cross alone I will
show today salvation can be achieved
without the cross blood sacrifice was
not necessary for salvation following
the law and repentance was enough to
achieve salvation
Paul is alone in his notion of salvation
by the cross the Old Testament the
synoptic tradition and James were not
consistent with Paul on this matter
Islam is an agreement with the Old
Testament and the Jesus tradition on
this matter there are a number of
atonement theories I wonder why
Christian scholars have to go through so
much trouble explaining the concept of
atonement via the cross and they have
come up with so many theories one of
them is ransom theory and the
satisfaction theory acceptance theory
penal theory which is what James white
believes in the government Theory mortal
theory and the Christus Victor theory
James he believes in penal substitution
Airy Theory which simply means that God
is very angry with humanity humans are
full of sin and a sacrifice must be done
to satisfy God it has to be done and
that is justice salvation in the Old
Testament we will start with the Old
Testament and see whether a salvation
was possible without blood sacrifice
because Paul he states in Hebrews 9:22
that without blood without a blood
sacrifice salvation cannot be achieved
or our sacrifice will not be accepted
however when we look at the Old
Testament we see so many passages so
many chapters so many instances where
salvation or forgiveness or redemption
was achieved without a blood sacrifice
for example we have the Book of Numbers
3150 where jewels were simply accepted
Leviticus 5:11 flour was good enough
Deuteronomy 9 18 Moses simply repents
for the people and the list goes on and
on and on
ammos 518 224 why would God not accept
their sacrifices Hosea 6:6 I desired
mercy not sacrifice in fact in chapter
14 verse 2
the Israelites state that we will offer
sacrifices from our lips we will offer
the the Bulls of our lips we cannot
offer Bulls anymore as blood sacrifice
for that reason we will simply repent
from our lips and we hope for our
forgiveness and there are so many
instances in in the Old Testament where
I can simply go on and on and on and
talk about salvation or redemption or
forgiveness is achieved without blood
sacrifice now in the Book of Ezekiel
chapter 18 verse 21 23 we read but if a
wicked man turns away from all the sins
he has committed and keeps all my
decrees and does what is just and right
he will surely live he will not die none
of the offences he has committed will be
remembered against him because of the
righteous things he has done
he will live simply he will follow the
law and he will live there is no need
for a blood sacrifice
you simply repent he follow the law the
rules the commandments of God and you
will be forgiven this is exactly what
islam teaches and we will see in due
course how islam is very consistent with
what the old testament teaches and what
jesus is thought to have taught when we
come to the New Testament the Gospel of
Matthew is a very interesting one it is
often called the gospel of the law
because it talks about the law so much
Jesus puts so much stress on following
the law and when a young man came to
Jesus in the Gospel of Matthew we are
told he asks Jesus what what is good for
me what do I do to achieve salvation or
success to achieve eternal life and
Jesus tells him to follow the
commandments simply follow the
commandments and you will have success
here is the point where Jesus should
have told him I have come to redeem you
to free you from sin to get you your
Redemption but he doesn't tell him that
there is another instance way we have
debated Christian scholars and activists
as to why Jesus cannot be God because he
missed many golden opportunities to
teach that to his followers and he never
taught that in the Gospel of Mark
chapter 29 verse 12 we are told that a
Jewish man he comes to Jesus and asks
him what is the first commandment and
Jesus tells him here o Israel the Lord
our God is one God worship thy Lord with
all thy heart with all thy mind with all
thy soul this is the point where Jesus
could have taught him I am the second
person in the Trinity that is the Holy
Spirit as well you the Jewish people
have been worshiping one God in one
person or in one being and you only knew
one person that's the father now things
have changed new covenant has come
across and there are two more persons
you have to worship Jesus didn't do that
likewise in the book of Matthew when
this young man comes to Jesus he asks
him about salvation about eternal life
and Jesus tells him simply follow the
commandments follow the law and then in
the Gospel of Matthew we are told that
you will never enter the kingdom of
heaven if you do not follow the
commandments of God so you can either
achieve eternal paradise or Hellfire by
doing charity or not doing charity again
in the Gospel of Matthew so we can go on
and on and on talking about the Gospel
of Matthew where Jesus Christ actually
talks about the importance of law
salvation through the law in fact in
chapter 5 verse 17
Jesus is believed to have said that
think not have come to abolish the law
rather have come to fulfill the law and
anyone who teaches you to go away from
the law even on a minor point or on one
point will be considered considered
least in the kingdom of heaven and we'll
see what Paul did later on Paul
completely broke away from the Jewish
law and he preached that that only faith
in the cross or faith in the sacrifice
of Jesus Christ is enough for salvation
you do not have to follow the law Paul
was very clear on that point
the Gospel of Luke and acts Luke was
written apparently or allegedly by Luke
and the book of Acts is also attributed
to a man called Luke whether Luke
actually wrote the gospel or the book of
Acts is another question altogether and
myself and dr. James white can debate
this topic another time the Canon and
authorship of the Gospels and the
controversy about the authorship I'm not
going to go into that let's assume for a
second or for the debate for the sake of
the discussion that Luke was indeed
written by a man called Luke
although these attributions were made to
these authors of these individuals in
the mid-second century years after these
documents are written and almost all
major Christian scholars a unanimous on
the point and I'm not talking about
liberal scholars I'm talking about
conservative scholars they are unanimous
that these documents were initially
written as synonymous sorry anonymous
documents so Luke amazingly omits when
he copies from mark and this is another
theory which follows follow that Luke
and Matthew they plagiarized from mark
much of the information they put into
the Gospels and when it comes to copying
from mark chapter 10 verse 45
Luke amazingly emits the salvific
formula he doesn't talk about and to
give his life a ransom for many in the
Gospel of Mark chapter 10 verse 45 we
read this part but in the Gospel of Luke
we do not see this part he simply omits
it I wonder why so even in the book of
acts omission of vicarious atonement in
acts is very visible to scholars
scholars have picked on that and they
have highlighted the point that the book
of Acts doesn't put much stress on
atonement by the cross one example is
when the story of the Ethiopian eunuch
is told and he is reading part
of Isaiah 53 and he asks Philip as to
what this means and Philip starts to
preach to him about Jesus without
telling him that this is actually
talking about the sacrifice of Jesus on
the cross and that sacrifice will atone
for your sins you will have salvation
through that Jesus doesn't go into that
I sorry Philip doesn't go into that so
this is a problem why would Luke if Luke
is the author of these two documents the
Book of Luke and the book of Acts why
does he not put stress on the issue of
atonement rather the central point in
the Gospel of Luke is that Jesus died as
an innocent man he was killed by the
Jewish scribes and priests innocently
and that is the point of the Gospel of
Luke this is what we see as the
prominent idea which Luke wants to
discuss in these documents at no place
does Luke state Jesus died for you or
for your sins even speeches and acts do
not contain the atonement theology who
think so dr. James dizzy done
I think dr. white will he will sorry
right it's okay no problem
dr. white sorry yeah that's okay
so James dizzy done he talks about this
problem the problem Luke not talking
about atonement an important corollary
to the acts sermons concentration on the
resurrection is the absence of any
theology of the death of Jesus his death
is mentioned but only as a bear fact
usually highlighting Jewish
responsibility the story historical fact
is not interpreted it is never said for
example that Jesus died on our behalf or
for our sins there are no suggestions
that Jesus death was a sacrifice in
other words in the synoptic tradition we
find very little evidence or very little
stress on the sacrifice of Jesus
the cross that we find in the writings
of Paul not in the synoptic tradition
and in the Gospel of Matthew as already
clarified we find a lot of stress on the
law following the law and that's where
the salvation is in the Gospel of Luke
Luke doesn't talk much about atonement
or anything like that
acts 20:28 seems to have a formula which
insinuates that there was a sacrifice
but not clearly and Dunn talks about
that even 20:28 the Church of the Lord
or God or of God which he obtained with
his own blood or with the blood of his
own not properly speaking part of an
even jealous tick even jelastic
proclamation remaining more than a
little puzzling and obscure in short and
explicit theology of the death of Jesus
is markedly lacking in the charisma of
the acts sermons he also states so far
as the krugman of the acts sermons is
concerned we have to say that it lacks a
theology of the cross
it makes no attempt to attribute a
definite atoning significance to the
death of Jesus Christ it mentions the
death of Jesus Christ but doesn't extend
that death to claim that this death was
actually a source of atonement for
Humanity now there's another problem in
the Gospel of Luke which apparently
talks about atonement but there is a
problem with it the problem is whether
we accept the longer ending of Luke 22
19 to 20 or whether we accept the
shorter ending I'm sure James is aware
of this problem and I'm not going to
spend much time on it and we can
possibly talk about it in the crossfire
but to highlight a simple point codex
beza
omits which is an early Greek manuscript
it omits the longer ending which
actually talks about Jesus this is my
body which is given for you do this in
remembrance of me and he did
in the same with the cup after supper
saying this cup that is poured poured
out for you is the New Covenant in my
blood so the words for you in the verse
19 and the formula for you in the verse
20
this part is omitted in D D is the name
of codex bezu which is an ancient Greek
manuscript and it is one of the earliest
witnesses that doesn't contain the
longer ending no doubt majority of the
Greek manuscripts do contain it this is
why people like bruce metzger scholars
like bruce metzger they believe that
this passage may be original it may be
original others disagree people like DC
Parker on Luke 22 20 people Eve the
shorter ending is likely to be the
original writing because it it is more
in line with Luke's theology it is more
in line with Luke's narrative his
language so Finland also concludes that
there is a problem there in the Gospel
of Luke that this longer ending does not
actually help the narrative rather it
creates a problem because of the
manuscript evidence which we can be
which can be discussed in due course the
Gospel of John John's Lamb of God that
takes away the sin of humanity now
amazingly when you put the synoptic
Gospels on one side and the Gospel of
John on the other side we do not see
this formula the Lamb of God put in the
synoptic tradition for some reason
John's Gospel has this formula this
extension of this story where John the
Baptist had baptized Jesus in the River
Jordan EP Sanders on John's Gospel he
states it is impossible to think that
Jesus spent his short ministry teaching
in to such completely different ways
conveying such different contents and
there were simply two traditions each
going back to Jesus one transmitting 50%
of what he said and another
or another one the other 50% which
almost no with almost no overlaps
consequently for the last hundred 50 or
so years scholars have had to choose and
they have almost unanimously and I think
entirely correctly concluded that the
teaching of the historical Jesus is to
be sought in the synoptic Gospels and
that John represents an advanced
theological development in which
meditations on the person and work of
Christ are presented in the first person
as if Jesus said them so scholars do
believe that the Gospel of John cannot
fully serve as a source of history of
Jesus rather synoptic tradition is to be
preferred now James versus Paul Paul is
the man who came up with this theory of
atonement salvation through the cross as
seen already that in the Old Testament
there are plenty of passages to claim or
to assert that salvation can be sought
or can be achieved by other means other
than blood sacrifice the Gospel of
Matthew tells us that Jesus put a stress
on the law follow the law and you will
have salvation you will have eternal
life Luke does not talk about atonement
to my knowledge and John cannot be
trusted when it comes to a story city of
these events so who are we left with
Paul and Martin Luther in the 16th
century believed that Paul and James are
two opposite ends they are opposing each
other theologically and James is saying
one thing and Paul is saying another and
it is impossible to reconcile them it is
impossible to reconcile them in fact for
this reason Martin Luther referred to
the Epistle of James as an epistle of
straw having praised it for his good
teachings for his usefulness and it can
be used by Christians isn't he has
nothing against those who use it but he
doesn't consider it any important he
thinks it's the it is an epistle of
straw why because James taught the law
James upheld the law he believed in
salvation through belief with works not
belief only as Paul put it there are so
many passages Colossians 2:16 where Paul
talks about not following the law
necessarily for salvation same formula
is repeated in Romans 3 19 to 28
Colossians 3:10 Colossians 3 24 25 Paul
is consistently saying that law is no
longer necessary the sacrifice of Jesus
has done it for us we don't have to
follow the law anymore we simply have to
believe in his sacrifice and we will
have salvation James on the other hand
he is on the other side of the fence
he states that you cannot believe and
not follow the law
you cannot have faith without good works
and that's what James was talking about
it seems the entire Epistle of James was
written on Paul and the rest will be
talked about in my 10 minutes when I
return thank you so much for listening
time thank you mr. Rasheed we will now
be heading into a rebuttal period dr.
white will start with his ten minute
rebuttal could we have a tech that could
possibly come up just to make sure that
our our laptops are you'd be using a
laptop I'm not I think we're okay
ordered we're doing fine and before we
start that at timer since since odd not
jump the gun okay yes I did remember you
odd none and you all are going to
appreciate this I have two gifts fraud
none the first
we'll help him get around Atlanta
tomorrow so what'd you do I've done is
you wear this and if anybody gives me
any trouble you go rise up and they'll
leave you alone okay so there you go
there's there's the sort of funny funny
one though it lets look like should be
fairly warm so that'd be pretty nice the
serious one I very much appreciate
that's a if you didn't know what that
was that's a basal Latin New Testament
over there I'm very very appreciative of
that but for you I have a real nice ESV
Study Bible here it's it's it's actually
small enough you might be able to get it
into your luggage and be able to get all
the way back to London so I did remember
you so thank you much I could take you I
I didn't forget I just normally wait to
a later point so okay here we go
all right so much it's so much to cover
there but I want to remain focused upon
the real the real key issues so let me
just deal with some of the major
statements that were made and then focus
upon what I think is the necessary thing
for us to be thinking about this evening
in what Adnan had just presented to us a
couple of things Luke and acts were said
there was there was a discussion of well
it's it's agreed that you know no one
really knows who wrote these things when
you actually look at Luke acts as a set
there are specific names mentioned I
mean if there is any of the New
Testament Gospels and early histories
that are specifically identified for us
as to their authorship it would be the
Luke acts pair so I'm not sure where
that comes from and it's interesting
that when we looked at mark 10:45 and
Mark specific language of Jesus giving
his life as a ransom for many it's it's
interesting he said well but Luke didn't
include that why not it's not that it's
it's not a question about Luke including
or not including it mark according to
the theories that he's presenting is
earlier than Luke so if this is
something that develops later on why
does the primitive gospel have it and
the later gospel not that that would be
backwards the point is if Mark has it
is extremely primitive and so it seems
to me that that that sort of are
actually militates against the position
he says well there is no there is no
atonement theology in acts well if what
you mean is there is no extended
discussions like you have in Hebrews or
Romans or places like that
ax is meant to be I personally think
that the the best theory for explaining
the the function of Acts is it was an
explanation as Paul is in prison because
it ends where we don't want to end isn't
it Paul's in prison we don't know what
happens I think one of the best theories
as to the very form and function of Acts
is it was like an amicus brief it was a
demonstration of what this early
Christian movement was about and a
demonstration that it was not something
that the Roman people the Roman
government should be persecuting and so
its focus is upon what the early history
was yes what the message was but it's
not meant to be a systematic theology
and yet as we saw in acts 2 in acts 4
absolutely central to the apostolic
proclamation was the cross the fact that
God predetermined it would happen and
that without the cross there can be no
forgiveness of sins just because it
doesn't dwell upon that or have chapters
of explication like the book of Hebrews
does does not mean that it was not a
part of the primitive teaching of the
church at that particular point in time
I would just very very quickly point out
that in Luke 22 19 codex Meza
cantabrigian says codex D that odd na
was speaking of is like the Living Bible
of the early church beza himself said it
was more to be stored than studied it is
the most variant manuscript in the in
the early period and that phraseology is
actually found in P 75 which is our best
early papyri which is of at least over
two hundred years earlier than beza sign
Atticus Vaticanus 579 and all the rest
the Byzantine manuscripts contain it as
well they just have it in a slightly
different phraseology where the last
word comes first and the rest of them
are the same so the phrase is found in
all but one of the Greek manuscripts and
that's a Latin dyg lot that is
extremely questionable in all the things
but I'd like to point out that very
phraseology is used in first corinthians
chapter 11 which if I'm correct I think
odd non dates Paul before Luke so that
would mean that that phraseology
predates Luke's writing of it so it's
not being there is not really an issue
we can get into the textual critical
stuff as you can tell that's something I
like to get into but I want to focus
upon something else right now
at the very beginning of odd nons
presentation i think we have the key to
this evenings discussion the I mean
might have been the first thirty seconds
might have been the first thirty seconds
where he used the phraseology erroneous
or abrogated he was talking about this
idea that well you know what Paul's
saying is it's just by faith and and I
really think that that Adnan has a
deficient understanding of Paul's
doctrine in Ephesians chapter 2 Paul
lays it out for by grace you have been
saved through faith and that not of
yourselves it is a gift of God not of
works lest any man should boast for we
are his workmanship created in Christ
Jesus what
unto good works which God has before
ordained that we walk in them John Paul
and James are not in contradiction with
one another if you follow James too
carefully I spent 24 pages on this
subject and the God who justifies follow
beginning at chapter 2 verse 14 they are
saying the exact same thing Paul
emphasizes that the very work of the
Spirit of God within us is to bring
about a conformance the image of Christ
that we do what is glorifying to him but
it is not the merit of my actions that
brings about my goodness before God and
that's the issue the itch issue is not
that the New Testament is saying that
those Old Testament laws were erroneous
or abrogated that's not what Paul was
saying that's not what any of the New
Testament writers are saying the proper
term is fulfilled not erroneous
not abrogated fulfilled that is they
pointed forward to something else and in
Jesus Christ the law finds its perfect
fulfillment so that when we are united
with him in dwelt by his spirit it then
becomes the work of the spirit and the
word to sanctify us and make us more
like Christ we can only truly fulfill
the law when we have died to the law in
Jesus Christ he is the one that's
fulfilled it perfectly we are united to
him by faith and then when we are born
again and made new creatures in him we
are indwelt by his spirit and empowered
to do what is pleasing before God not to
add to our righteousness but to glorify
God this is the balanced understanding
when you take all of the New Testament
and obviously odd nuns got to take all
the New Testament because if you're
quoting
D James D G done and people like that
you've already started with the
presupposition that the New Testament is
an incoherent contradictory work well
the problem is well you may certainly
believe that but if my if we do a debate
on what the Quran teaches on this I'm at
least gonna start off by saying well
consistently if we can if we allow all
the Quran to speak this is the position
and so let's debate that position but in
general mainly because the New
Testaments so much bigger than then the
Quran is as a whole I mean it's with the
Quran Zwilling like 53% the length of
the New Testament be in in most of the
conversations we end up having between
myself my Muslim friends the assumption
is that you can create contradiction
between the New Testament writers rather
than stepping back and going is there a
consistent way of hearing everything
that the New Testament writers are
saying I say to you that there is it's
the concept of fulfillment so for
example he brought up the issue of the
rich young ruler and say see here's
here's what we Muslims muscles believe
you you you do you do the law and you're
gonna be right with God but that misses
what happened
isn't it doesn't that miss it the man
walks away sad why because he had many
possessions
and you see Jesus had known when he
quoted the law to this man he knows that
as the Prophet Jeremiah says over and
over again
he knows the heart of man and my friends
this evening I'll just be perfectly
honest with you the the only way for us
really to come to any kind of agreement
understanding on this issue is for each
one of us in the light of God's word to
look at our own heart and ask the
question if it's up to me if it's up to
me if I'm the one that has to bring
repentance out of my own heart if I'm
the one has to keep that law am I going
to fail or am I going to succeed one of
the things we gonna need to talk about
as we get into this conversation more is
when you say that that's the Muslim
position well what about for example the
salvation of the man who killed 99
people and killed one hundredth person
and Allah takes him to heaven over
against some of the Sahaba
who wept at their death because they
were uncertain whether they they were
going to enter into a laws presence
there was there is no objective means of
knowing which you're going to be facing
and the real question comes down to as I
look into my own heart don't I realize
that if it is up to me I'm not gonna
make it I need a powerful mediator to
stand between me and that holy God
that's what joe said I need a mediator
and we have that mediator and in Islam
you don't have that mediator that's
really where the issue is is the law a
matter of fulfillment Christ has done it
and now by his Spirit he's working that
within us is the cross necessary yes
when we recognize the power of God seen
in it thank you very much thank you dr.
white we now have a ten minute rebuttal
from mr. Rashid
so I was talking about James and Paul
dr. white came back and he talked about
the sacrifice again and what Paul had
said and I don't understand Paul's
theology I understand Paul's theology
perfectly well I simply don't have the
time to go through pause evolving
theology in his epistles what I need to
do is to show that Paul's theology of
the cross was not consistent with the
Old Testament primarily and then the
synoptic tradition because the synoptic
authors Matthew Mark and Luke are
clearly not interested in what Paul had
to say later on nor doubt scholars
believe that Paul wrote before the the
three Gospels or the four Gospels
there's no doubt about that this is why
some people believe that Paul actually
influenced some of the redactors of
these Gospels now James said there is no
evidence for you know textual variations
of certain passages I quoted most
textual scholars believe that majority
of the changes or alterations in to the
manuscripts of the New Testament were
made before the second century they were
made before the second century and most
of our manuscripts come from the second
century onwards so by the time these
manuscripts we have today in
international lab libraries around the
world by the time they were penned all
the alterations had already been made
into these manuscripts we simply cannot
reach the original texts that venture is
already over the scholars of textual
criticism or the textual history of the
Bible have already declared that we are
not no longer looking for the original
text of Mark Luke Matthew and John
because we simply cannot find it it is
impossible to reach it in the 21st
century or to reconstruct a book that
was written in the 1st century ce e
coming back to the topic again James
versus Paul I still believe that James
was a very important figure who is
ignored
generally speaking in
the Christian circles because there is a
lot of stress on Paul's doctrine of
salvation through the cross it's a
beautiful idea someone was killed on the
cross Jesus Christ albeit Jesus Christ
and he freed you from sin he freed you
from the wrath of God you have the
redemption right he died for your sins
so you have the salvation it's a
beautiful idea if I didn't know what I
know today or what I have I have known
for years I would be a Christian it's a
beautiful idea but I cannot simply come
around to overcome these troubling
issues we are discussing today so James
was an important figure in in according
to Paul even Paul acknowledged in his
writings that James is a very important
figure in fact we have we have been told
by later historians such as Eusebius and
others that James was the leader of the
Jerusalem church James was the successor
of Jesus Christ whc friend another
historian patristic historian states
that James was the actual leader of the
church the man who decided many of the
matters concerning the flock of Jesus
Christ after his departure so in the
book of Acts we are told about these
discussions where Paul is having these
discussions with James and the counsel
of the disciples of Jesus Christ and lo
and behold guess what what are they
actually discussing they are discussing
that the matter of the law Paul is
adamant that the Gentiles don't have to
follow the law of the the Jewish people
on the other hand we have James the just
or the brother of Jesus Christ insisting
that they have to follow some law such
as abstaining from meat that is
sacrificed by the for the idols the
issue of circumcision is being discussed
so if Jesus has died on the cross for
our sins he has redeemed us why are
these discussions taking place in
Jerusalem between Paul and the disciples
of Jesus Christ what is the point why
not why can't Paul simply tell them it's
over we don't need to discuss the matter
of law you know Jesus died for our sins
this certainly didn't believe what Paul
believed in that's why there was a
conflict between James and Paul that's
why Martin Luther in the sixteenth
century had trouble in reconciling James
and Paul and he made the statement that
you can see on the screen many sweat
hard at reconciling James and Paul but
unsuccessfully faith justifies Paul
stands in flat contradiction to faith
does not justify alone James 2:24 if
anyone can harmonize these sayings I'll
put my doctors cap on him and let him
call me a fool Martin Luther so it is
clear that James and Paul are both
standing on opposite sides of the fence
and James was definitely an
authoritative figure he was very close
to Jesus Christ he spent time with Jesus
Christ he was one of those people who
spent months with Jesus Christ and
learnt directly from Jesus Christ on the
other hand we have Paul who appears to
have received this revelation after
Jesus Christ and his revelation seems to
abrogate everything Jesus did such as
teaching the importance of the law Jesus
telling his followers that you will not
have salvation you will not you will not
have it and alive until your
righteousness exceeds the righteousness
of Pharisees and the scribes what does
that mean why did why despise Jesus
telling them that if he is going to die
for the sins of his disciples primarily
and the rest of the world this is the
point to tell his disciples don't worry
about it
don't worry about the law I'm going to
die soon for your sins there's nothing
to worry about but he keeps on telling
them do not break the law observe the
law follow the Jewish law this is a
messianic figure a Jewish prophet
teaching Jews and in fact some people
even claim that he only came for the
Jews as he himself stated in the book of
Matthew chapter 15 verse 24 that I did
not come for anyone but to the lost
sheep of the house of Israel
then in chapter 28 verse 19 in the book
of Matthew we are told that he said to
his disciples they're going to the
nations to baptize them in the name of
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
right and some of the scholars current
scholars today conservative scholars not
liberals or someone who rejects
supernaturalism people like Graham
Stanton he states that this passage is a
later development because in the book of
Acts we are told that the disciples were
baptizing in the name of Jesus not in
the name of a Trinity in the book of
Matthew we are told that jesus said to
his disciples to baptize in the name of
three persons so are the Christians
guaranteed salvation let's assume for a
second that Jesus did die on the cross
for our sins but when we read some of
the passages in the New Testament in
fact writings of Paul we come to realize
that actually salvation is not
guaranteed it is not guaranteed at all
why do you not know that the unrighteous
will not inherit the kingdom of God do
not be deceived neither fornicators nor
idolaters nor adulterers nor homosexuals
nor sodomites nor thieves or nor
covetous nor drunkards nor revilers nor
extortioners will inherit the kingdom of
God none of these people then who did
Jesus died for is the question if Jesus
died for his sins then how does that
sacrifice actually benefit here Paul
seems to be saying that if you do these
things then you do not have the kingdom
of heaven you do not inherit it and
another passage in Colossians 5:19
everyone seems to be doomed why think
about it now the works of the flesh are
evident which are adultery fornication
uncleanness lasciviousness idolatry
sorcery hatred contentions jealousies
outbursts of Wrath selfish ambitions
dissensions heresies Envy murders
drunkenness you name it now if we read
this list
and think about it then the question I
ask is who is safe who is safe every
single one of us is doomed
every single one of them and we don't
know to what extent what is the
magnitude of these sins how much or how
many do we have to commit in order to
lose salvation to lose the kingdom of
God or the kingdom of heaven how many -
what ik to what exact extent is Paul
referring here is just one transgression
enough is a repetitive sinning if so how
regular are these various sins
hierarchical in other words are all the
sins weighed equally or are some some
worse than others don't all Christians
all of humanity even have selfish
ambitions and jealousies do we not drink
some of us I don't but do do people not
drink Christians who believe in the
cross do they not drink so do you have
salvation according to the writings of
Paul do you is the question so there are
problems and in this passage in front of
me the time is up so I will have to come
back to some of these issues in the next
rebuttal thank you so much for listening
thank you mr. Rashid okay ladies and
gentlemen we're now gonna give you a
10-minute break before we start our
cross examination period also during
this time if you'd like to be able to
take some pieces of paper and bring one
question per person up here we would
like to have one question for dr. white
and one question for Adnan Rashid as
well and so we can take a look at those
I will pick the best three for each been
at the end okay thank you so much we'll
see you in 10 minutes okay ladies and
gentlemen first of all I want to take
time to recognize and to thank Josh Pais
and the g3 conference and all of their
volunteers for really allowing us to put
this debate on once again what a great
time last year and once again this year
we are really delving deep
some things in the cross-examination is
always I think the most scintillating of
the times that we have but it is great
that unlike many of the debates that
I've moderated over the past 20 years
that these two gentlemen do respect each
other so what I don't believe what
you're gonna be hearing is any game
playing which sadly that's something
that you see quite often in
cross-examination periods so a lot of
this I believe will be quite easy for me
now one thing that I want to ask of you
I know that we have many people that are
in our audience that are apologists that
many of you are brilliant scholars in
your own right and so forth
I would ask please though that you
refrain from commenting out loud during
the debate and holding your own debate
or your responses to two odd none or to
dr. white if you could please I would
ask please keep the chatter down during
the debate please I've already had many
people come up to me and complain about
some of these things we're all
Christians let's just say that you know
even during well not all of us are
Christians of this sorry yes I know yes
we do have a mixed audiences which is
what we wanted anyway yes but we all do
want to respect each other and if you
are able to you know although I was not
able to to keep my mouth shut
during the last Star Wars film and
throwing my popcorn at the screen and
nearly getting kicked out I just hope
that you could respect the event itself
other people have paid and have taken
pains to be here
I would imagine many of you that are
here are not native Floridian sore
Georgians that you're able to drive for
the snow to get here but if you could
please just respect those that are
around you that are here to listen to
each one of the apologists and to be
able to then formulate those things in
their own minds and with that we are
going to start the cross-examination
period dr. white cross-examining odd nan
Rasheed and then and then mr. Rasheed
will be cross-examining dr. white all
right
I have a timer so we're good okay odd
none before everyone forgets what you
were just saying well everyone already
has but we'll assume that they haven't
you just quoted from first Corinthians
chapter 6 verses 9 through 10 and you
basically said well then for whom did
Christ die was was that whatever stood
you were saying yeah okay do you do you
have a Bible program up or could you use
that really nice ESV Study Bible they
gave you or whatever however could could
you read the very next verse after the
one you quoted you want me to read them
out well I can read it for you if you
like okay such were some of you but you
were washed but you were sanctified but
you were justified in the name of the
Lord Jesus Christ in the spirit of our
God
so the statement that Paul is making is
all those things the the idolaters
fornicators thieves covetous drunkards
swindlers such were some of you but
there was a radical change but you were
washed but you were sanctified the only
way you could be washed is in the blood
of Christ
so doesn't doesn't the text actually
answer the question and that is anyone
who can turn in faith anyone who turns
in faith to Jesus Christ even these
people who listed here will find him to
be the one who is able to bring about
their sanctification and justification
is isn't that the very what the very
next verse says yes it does but you have
to read Paul holistically right this is
what I've learned from you Paul
you have to read Paul holistically
holistically yes right and when you read
Paul I mean for example Hebrews 6:46 it
is impossible for those who have once
been enlightened who have tests who have
tasted the heavenly gift who have shared
in the Holy Spirit who have tasted the
goodness of the word of God and the
powers of the coming age and who have
fallen away to be brought back to
repentance so here Paul is talking about
someone who has had the Holy Spirit
someone someone who has been a
lightened someone who has believed in
the sacrifice of Jesus Christ and if
someone goes away it is impossible to
bring such a person back so there is no
salvation if if you have believed in the
cross and somehow break the rules of the
cross whatever they are you cannot be
brought back according to this passage
this is how I understand it yes guess
which guess what the passage of the
sermon from last Sunday that I preached
was ok Hebrews chapter 6 right so if you
have it how do you respond to that then
if well it's my turn to ask you
questions I'd love to do that but if you
have it up you could look at verses 9
and 10 and you'll notice that Paul says
but we are well and I we're not sure
that Paul wrote Hebrews you directly
said that he was but I theoretically
think that he did but that's that's a
other issue its passivity the writer
specifically states but we are convinced
of better things concerning you things
which accompany salvation so I think
that is a misapplication of Hebrews 6
first of all especially what comes
afterwards to the end of the chapter but
going back to 1st Corinthians chapter 6
the point is and and you said reading
him holistically well first you got to
read him in his initial context he is
saying that all of these kinds of people
can be saved because of the cross dude
would you at least say that that's
what's being said in 1st Corinthians
chapter 6 okay let's assume that's true
let's assume for a second that's true
does that mean that anyone who believes
in the cross can do all those things I'm
not saying they wouldn't
I'm not asking whether they would if
someone who believes in the cross and
continues to commit adultery and drink
fornicate lie cheat steal right are you
familiar with with Paul's words and the
book of Romans when he says shall we
continue in sin that grace may increase
may it never be how shall we who died to
sin still live in it I know of that and
asking what I'm not asking whether they
would I'm asking if they would if they
did let's say someone believes who
believes in the cross who believes in
the sacrifice of Jesus Christ who died
for our sins okay
if someone if
one was to commit those sins what would
you say about that that would be a good
question for you to ask me during the
during your time to ask me questions
where we're trying to be focused on
something here okay
you have you have stated a number of
times that you believe that the Apostle
Paul is opposed to the law that he
teaches somehow in a way that is
completely opposed to Jesus and the
Apostles on the issue of of the law
could I direct your attention to Romans
chapter 3 for a second right assuming
that you would agree with me that the
Paul I don't believe Paul was opposed to
the law I don't believe that I believe
he contradicted the Old Testament as
well as the Jesus tradition and James
okay he contradicted it by stating it
was not God's law or or what he simply
stated that you have to believe in the
cross or you have to believe in Jesus
Christ and you don't need to follow the
law do good deeds that are planning the
passages I can
okay this regard okay but good when you
say you don't have to do good deeds so
your understanding as he was saying that
your good deeds cannot save you no my
understanding is that you do not have to
good do good deeds for salvation to gain
it or or that it's the purpose of
salvation simply to have salvation Paul
is saying you just have to believe in
Jesus Christ and his sacrifice and you
have salvation without works and so when
you want me to read some passages well
believe me I I'm just wanting to ask you
I'm just asking you to explicate why
then does he say that it is God's
purpose that we walk in good works
walking in doing good work do you want
me to give the text I'm sorry I forgot
to give you the test sorry do you want
me to read the text to you no no it's
okay it's fine
doing good DS is one thing I'm not
saying Paul is telling people not to do
good deeds I never claimed that I never
claimed that and I never will claim that
I'm saying Paul's view or
that you just have to believe in Jesus
Christ's sacrifice and you have
salvation and when we read others they
said they're contradicting him people
like James in chapter 2 James is simply
in fact calling someone a fool for
believing that I don't know I'm some
people claim that James like for example
do you want to be shown you senseless
person that faith apart from works is
barren was not our ancestor Abraham
justified by works when he offered his
son Isaac on the altar right now this
this is from Genesis 15 right
well no Genesis 22 no 15 Genesis 15 this
is from Genesis now money offers the
sacrifice now know this passage is from
Genesis 15:6 if I don't well that's that
we're talking about offering are you
talking about the offering of Isaac yes
that's not Genesis 14 I'm talking about
Abraham's initial justification yeah
yeah that's right six yeah yeah that's
it so James is quoting that so it's Paul
Paul takes a completely different view
of that passage that very verse or that
passage from James so you have you read
my 24 page chapter on James chapter 2
which deals with this in depth right but
does it clarify does it justify it if I
wrote it I wonder if Luther couldn't
others like Luther couldn't reconcile
James and Paul I don't know how we can
do it today I'll try to I'll try to fit
it into my closing to explain why that
is but the point is it sounds like you
think that James is saying that you that
faith in Christ is not enough and that
that's only part of it and that your
good works have merit that add to what
Christ did know what I understand from
James is James is saying that your faith
alone without works is not enough that
alone faith accompanied by works
is real that's real faith and what was
that faith in that's that faith is in
Jesus Christ of course which you don't
believe in which who you don't believe
that faith in Jesus Christ is gonna say
believe I believe in Jesus Christ I mean
I know you my views on the Sun is that
hey the Jewish Messiah and I rather
believe in Jesus Christ like Christians
do today no I don't Aurel as James would
have I believe I mean look that's
another issue now do we have what James
might have written completely do we have
I mean the Epistle of James was
problematic right I'm trying to help you
here problematic yeah it was considered
non canonical by many Church Fathers as
you are well aware of it it is like it
is missing in the lists of many Church
Fathers and Luther er actually in his
writings alludes to that point that
James was not even considered canonical
about many Church Fathers further for
the reasons he stated that it
contradicts Paul and it law it
it lacks apostolic Authority these are
the words of Luther and I have the
quotes here with me I can read them if
you want so James were war was a
contested book right the time is time
okay mister Rasheed's
time to ask dr. white questions well dry
it go ahead and repeat again is that we
do want to make sure that one person is
asking questions and the other person is
saying we're trying we're trying okay
maybe I'm too imposing not at all all
right okay
James question number one we read the
Old Testament and we find passages all
over the place that Israelites simply
repent and God forgive them we have
similar passages in the New Testament
where we are asked to repent and we will
be forgiven
so why does God have to kill his son to
forgive us
why can't he simply like in Islam we
believe that you simply turn to God and
ask for repentance and you will have
your forgiveness
what why constantly got God simply
forgive us well if you read all of the
Old Testament and allow all of it to
speak there's this there's this huge
swath called the Mosaic law and that law
has a function that function is to show
us our sin and to bring conviction of
that sin and you have this incredible
thing called Yom Kippur dream the day of
atonement you have high priests you have
sacrifices and this this theme is found
in all of the prophets and and all the
historical works and so when I see God
calling Israel to repent and he will
forgive I don't interpret that outside
the light of the fact that God has
established this law and when I look at
that law odd NAM it demands the shedding
of blood for the forgiveness of sin and
it it does provide for other kinds of
sacrifices Thanksgiving sacrifices oil
sacrifices at cetera cetera yes but when
it comes to it's sometimes called Yom
Kippur but it's really Yom Kippur deem
it sits there multiple atonement so
we're made on that day Leviticus chapter
16 there is the necessity of the
shedding of blood and the highest point
in the Jewish religious year is when the
high priest enters into the holy place
with the sacrifice right what James when
you claim necessity I'm sorry when you
claim necessity what is that necessity
for the reason I'm looking back it I can
hear you better back here than right
over there necessity of what when you
said the necessity of blood sacrifice
yes
it's late it's specifically laid out in
the law where as part of the covenant
documents the relationship that God has
with his pea
so what happened to all those Israelites
who couldn't do that the temple was
destroyed and they were in exile and
what happened then which which time of
the destruction the first time and the
second okay well in in in the first
after the first time of the destruction
yes you have God rebuilt having the
temple rebuilt so you have Nehemiah not
not immediately as we know
well there's Cyrus right right there's
there's a period if there's a period of
Exile but when he brings the people back
in that period of Exile what what are
the Israelites doing for for their
salvation for the forgiveness well but
your misunderstanding is saying I don't
believe that it was the doing of those
actions of the law that brought
salvation it's when you look at what
those actions were they were pointing to
something more right they were prophetic
and in fact I'm not sure that a I'm not
sure that a Muslim is consistent and
arguing against this and here's why
you believe in prophetic utterances yes
we do the Quran itself
I'm not wasn't asking I'm sorry I'm just
making a statement there but for example
the Quran says that the people of the
book find prophecies of Muhammad in
their scriptures yes so we see and the
New Testament plainly teaches for
example the book of Hebrews the
fulfillment of what is found in the
types and shadows in the sacrifices that
point to a greater sacrifice that is a
sacrifice of Jesus Christ
so when I read the Psalter and I read
David pouring out his heart in
repentance toward God and God grants
forgiveness I recognize that there must
be a grounds upon which God can give
that forgiveness and that's where you
and I have a fundamental disagreement
but then would you agree we have I'm
sorry I'm sorry go ahead if that is the
case James if these are prophetic
passages or prophetic ideas in the Old
Testament where blood sacrifice has
something to say for the future right
why didn't Jesus simply explain that to
his disciples why didn't he say look at
these examples all these examples in the
past
I am the fulfillment I will die for your
sins on the cross like he didn't tell
you 24:44 sorry Luke 24:44 through 45
right what is this thing after the
resurrection he meets with his disciples
and he says everything that is written
about me in the law of Moses the Psalms
and the prophets must be fulfilled no
atonement is that it's the issue here
atonement where is where does he tell
them that I am that atonement by that
redemption okay the only way that we can
know because we have we have two verses
that tell us that Jesus did all this
talking to disciples we're not told what
he said you know how we can find out
what he said
the sermons and the writings of the
people that followed and spread his
message right and so when we look at how
the Old Testament is used in the
preaching in acts acts 2:24 it acts for
quotes directly from the Old Testament
what's it about the suffering of the
Messiah
you see Isaiah 53 being brought in
where'd they get these ideas I would say
they got them from Jesus Isaiah 53 is a
very interesting passage you know
Christians believe that it is a prophecy
for the the sacrifice of Jesus Christ
you know Jewish rabbis have disagreed
with you for centuries right yes well
aware but there is there is something I
I have come across in Isaiah 53 which is
very interesting you when you were
reading the passage you actually talked
about or you you mentioned I didn't
really write so I didn't read the entire
chapter no you reread the part I'm
talking yeah where it simply states that
he will see his offspring yes and then
you said this is the offspring you had
to stop there and you had to explain
what offspring actually means why is
that because when we go to Hebrew there
is this word zero cierra right which
means offspring and according to Hebrew
lexicons we are told that this actually
means semen literally the substance that
produces offspring and it is very
similar to
the Arabic term Zuria I'm aware of the
Arabic language so Hebrew and Arabic
languages are sister languages very
similar to each other
so here the Jewish rabbis this is why
the Jews find it very difficult to
believe that this is about Jesus because
it simply states that he will see his
offspring now and we cannot blame the
Jews for holding the zoo because they
have their linguistic tradition and they
interpret this passage or this
particular verse in the light of that
linguistic tradition and prolong his
days is there a question in here so how
how can you ignore that that the
linguistic side of I didn't dig ignore
because the seed of Abraham is as the
stars of the c2 of the star of the sky
so obviously this is not meant to be
taken in a literal fashion this is a
poetic section you'll notice it says
right before that if he would render
himself as a guilt offering well how can
someone be rendered as a guilt offering
under the Old Testament law this is
obviously poetic and when you look at it
you have to ask the questions well what
does this mean when it says he will see
his offspring he will prolong his days
that doesn't means you have a bunch of
kids what it what when you when you look
at everything that it says my servant
will justify the many as he will bear
their iniquities so you choose to to
interpret certain verses literally and
others metaphorically this is a prophecy
yes and so prophecy has to be taken in
such a fashion as to have a fulfillment
right and when you look at all of this
and say okay what one thing can fulfill
all of this there's only one thing that
can there is note there is no place
where the nation of Israel for example
the normal rabbinic interpretation that
could ever fulfill all of these things
and in fact there's a number of places
where the nation itself is in view as
the object of the redemption he will
bear their iniquities who will bear
their iniquities the people of Israel
bear the people of iniquity of neutral
iniquities that doesn't make any sense
but Jewish rabbis and Jewish scholars
have written books on this Bible yes
they have and we've written books in
response and I think point people to the
debates that have been done on that I
think they're actually
conclusive but from a Muslim perspective
I am confused by your criticism of the
text because the Quran identifies Jesus
as the mashiac yes
how were the Jews supposed to know Jesus
was the Messiah if they're if these are
not the very prophetic texts that would
have held them accountable for knowing
that one of the reasons why I was not
supposed to ask okay I'm just going to
respond to that very quickly one of the
reasons why Jewish priests at the time
rejected Jesus was that he was killed on
the cross allegedly and they had this
view that the Messiah cannot be killed
Psalms 91 where it is clearly stated
that he will be saved God will protect
him and that's one of the problems we
can discuss in due course so that's why
the Quran confirms that that he was not
killed on the cross he was the Messiah
promised to the Jews Jesus was not
killed on the cross he was saved he was
lifted up he was raised high he ascended
to the heavens and that's it okay so now
I'm asking asking questions of you
pretend continues what you just said
though it struck me you said one of the
reasons that the Jews rejected Jesus was
because he died on the cross how do you
make that fit with Sura 4:157 and it's
denial of the historical reality of the
crucifixion of Jesus I mean we're not
debating that but it's obviously central
to to this issue you can't even really
seriously consider what the New
Testament says about the death of Christ
because you don't believe it actually
took place I'm I accept that the four
Gospels are unanimous all the historical
record we have at our disposal tells us
that Jesus was crucified
however the Quran tells us that he was
not crucified and the Old Testament also
agrees with that according to what we
understand for example I mean this is
something I would like to highlight very
quickly when we go to the book
Psalms sorry Psalms 91 and we see the
book of Matthew actually referred to
this passage where when we read the
entire book sorry let me find the
passages I'm talking about they seem to
have lost 91 11 he for he will give his
angels charge concerning you to guard
you in all the ways he'll bury up in
your hands that you don't strike your
foot against um right and yeah basically
in the Book of Luke chapter 4 verse 10
and Matthew 4 chapter 4 verse 5 6 there
is a dialogue between the devil and
Jesus Christ right and the devil tells
Jesus Christ that you will be saved
right and well there are striking
similarities between what the wording
devil uses and what we find in Psalms 91
and Psalms 91 is entirely about someone
being saved verse 3 for example surely
he will save you verse 4 he will cover
you verse 5 you will not fear verse 8
you will only observe with your eyes and
see the punishment of the wicked verse
10 that no harm will befall you verse 11
for he will command his angels
concerning you to guard you in all your
ways they will lift lift you up in their
hands and this is very much in agreement
in the quran the quran says that he was
saved from crucifixion and he was lifted
up he was simply lifted up he was raised
above so that you will not strike your
foot against a stone this is the point
this is where it agrees word by word
with matthew 4 chapter 4 verse 5 6 so
jesus doesn't actually deny the passage
it doesn't say it's not me
that pass is talking about rather jesus
says it also states in the scripture he
confirms what the devil says and it also
states in the scripture do not tempt God
mm-hmm right
so book of Matthew
clearly states that Psalms 91 refers to
Jesus Christ when we read Psalms 91 we
see he is being saved he's not killed
how do you respond to that what do we do
with that yeah well it's actually my
turn to ask you questions but wouldn't
you understand that the fact that Jesus
is resurrected from the dead as the
ultimate form of salvation is how I
answer that question by asking you a
question
[Laughter]
wouldn't you recognize however that any
type of of shadow can not be as clear as
its fulfillment so in other words
prophecy in the Old Covenant has to be
by nature less than its than its
fulfillment so if you're saying that the
the Old Testament prophecies have to be
identical to what happens in the New
Testament then you can't have a greater
mediator or greater covenant or any of
those things you're limited only to Old
Testament categories so how do you how
do you how do you how do you answer the
question how were the Jews who both know
Jesus was the Messiah by his words it's
very simple by him claiming to be the
Messiah based upon what he read from the
Old Testament so so the old so Jesus is
Jesus could make reference to the Old
Testament say this proves that I'm the
Messiah yes yes so where is there any
place in the Old Testament where there
is a prophecy that could possibly live
up to the level of clarity that you just
demanded from Psalm 91 by the way it's
Psalms 91 Psalms 91 yes it's not Psalms
song right okay you don't say Songs 91
that's right Psalm 91 - Oh Psalms the
book of sorry
just a little pen sorry I was it was
like you're pulling your fingernails
down right so well Howie when we read
this chapter it is very clear that is
talked
a Masonic figure who will be saved right
and then the book of Matthew tells us
that this passage is talking about Jesus
it's very very perplexing that then
Matthew Luke and Mark go on to claim
that Jesus died on the cross so you have
known that this so your assumption is
that dying on the cross is not being
saved
even though Matthew Mark Luke and John
also say he is then resurrected and
exalted at the right hand of the Father
which is the greatest form of salvation
that could ever be no but if you read
the chapter 91 it's clearly states that
he will not suffer he will not suffer
you will not fear Jesus was clearly in a
state of fear right we know the passages
where he fell on his face and he praise
the gods of Gethsemane right and there
are other passages here alright we're
gonna have disagree on how you how you
can even come up with the these issues
but you say that you said that Paul
originated the atonement theory was that
your direct state atonement by a human
sacrifice yeah in in in in in the form
of Jesus Christ dying on the cross there
are some theories that Paul had to come
up with that because the Jewish people
had rejected the killed Messiah they
simply couldn't believe in a messiah who
was killed on the cross or who was hung
on a tree and as the Old Testament is
very clear about that that would be a
curse right and Paul the first with that
curse and turns that curse into a
positive thing so yeah so if that's the
case though and James is actually
writing against Paul why is there no
condemnation of its Holman theology and
the Epistle of James well that's what it
is when James is telling whoever he's
telling what he's telling that you
cannot you cannot have faith alone but
that works but you that's not it's only
theology in other words if if in fact
this radical thing does not find its
origination in Psalm 22 and in and in
Isaiah 53
but Paul came up with it then wouldn't
that be the central aspect of the book
of James so that is the atonement
theology of Paul Paul talks about the
law no longer being necessary because of
the sacrifice of Jesus Christ's law has
become unnecessary because Jesus died on
the cross for us I have passages here
does James does James ever use the term
atonement and so it doesn't because I
don't think the term was even even
invented at that time or was well well
propitiating there's there's all sorts
of terms to be used but yeah but when
you when you actually read James
it's a Epistle exhorting people to live
the Christian life this idea that's some
corrective I don't even know where it
comes from but but there's nothing in in
the Epistle that even addresses the idea
of denying substitutionary atonement the
sacrifice of Christ and in fact 'men let
me just ask you to look at one one text
and and tell me if it doesn't seem too
you know sound just like Paul James
chapter 1 verse 18 in the exercise of
his will
he brought us forth by the word of truth
so that we would be a kind of
firstfruits among his creatures I mean
that sounds like Romans chapter 8 so why
is he using Pauline language if he's
actually trying to correct Paul that
actually proves my point
that's that's a point in my favor
because when people refuse to accept
that James is actually talking to Paul
when he says you foolish man you
senseless man people say it's not talk
he's not talking to Paul but if you're
claiming that he's talking his dude in
Paul's language that means he's actually
talking to Paul but in agreement no he's
all the Apostles would use this language
right so what but you're missing the
point
I'm saying if if you're claiming that
James was using Paul's language that
means he knew Paul's language that's the
case he's talking to Paul and he's
calling him a foolish man well the
private in James 2:14
it specifically says can a faith that
has no evidence of his existence save do
you think that's actually what Paul was
teaching Paul was teaching that like for
example let's let's let's read it sorry
if everyone could please silence there
so the time elapsed and I could I didn't
get to it fast enough right
okay my turn cancel it's supposed to
stop I don't know why it doesn't this is
the last ten minutes right all right
it's all yours right so as we're talking
about James and Paul look James is
talking about and let's see what he has
to say what good is it my brothers and
sisters if you say you have faith but do
not have works can faith save you okay
you you're starting you're starting way
to get far into the passage I'm reading
James 2:14 which is what you referred to
right yeah that's what it states and
then it goes on in verse 20 same chapter
do you want to be shown you senseless
senseless person or in some translations
you foolish man that faith apart from
works is barren yes was not was not our
ancestor Abraham justified by works when
he offered his son Isaac on on the altar
you see that faith was active along with
his works and faith was brought to
completion by the works I'm gonna ask if
we have a copy of the God who justifies
in the back and if we do I'm going to
personally pay for it and ask that it be
given thank you - brother - can you
bring that up brother - Anna doesn't
another present for you because I liked
her I can't I can't summarize a 24 page
exegesis right now but let me just let
me just do this for you okay what use is
it my brethren if someone says he has
faith but he has no works
can that face-saving pissed us has the
Greek article there it is functioning to
say this kind of faith it is a faith
that cannot give evidence of its
existence that is the faith that is
being issued and condemned throughout
this text and it is never ever Paul's
teaching that the faith that is produced
by the Spirit of God in the elective in
the hearts of the elect of God's people
is that kind of faith okay I'll stop you
there because you're doing now exegesis
right yes okay that's what you have to
do what's Jay let's go to the to the
book of Acts well this is where the
discussion is taking place on the issue
of law this very issue we're talking
about this is where the problem was Paul
was in Jerusalem to justify himself for
what he was doing jihad acts 18 yes I'm
talking about a book of Acts s as long
you know yeah for the Jerusalem Council
and actually getting exactly so why are
they discussing law why are they even
discussing it when Paul himself is
clearly preaching to people that it is
not necessary to follow the law anymore
because Jesus died for our sins so so so
and Paul was according to the book of
Acts accused of that very thing that
very idea actually if you look at Acts
chapter 15 odd non the Paul does give
testimony concerning his ministry
amongst the Gentiles but who gets up
after him so sorry but who gets up after
him Peter right and Peter then testifies
in support of what Paul is saying and
then James concludes by saying what
we're to write this letter to the
Gentiles and these are the things that
are necessary to maintain you know unity
amongst the believers but there is no
condemnation of Paul they agree with the
message that we are justified by faith
just as the Gentiles so what was the
conclusion of James but and there are
two issues here James in is sitting in
judgment do you agree in acts 15 yes
well he's the
is the he is the person in charge of the
council thank you but that means but
it's not that that do not mean that he
was a pope or he was no I didn't claim
that no but he isn't he is running the
show we have plenty of evidence to to
claim that James was the leader of no
question the flock or the community or
the Christians if you know called him
that although they won't call Christians
at this stage as you know the book of
Acts tells us that Christians the word
Christian he's the bishop of the day
he's one of the bishops of the Jerusalem
church I don't even know the term bishop
is the right term to use for James at
that time because James is still going
to the temple
he's busy observing the law is arguing
for the law he's a zealot he's a zealot
for the law these are the words I'm
using biblical words here biblical terms
to describe James as he's described in
in in the Bible so when Wales gives his
judgment he talks about certain rules
and laws to be followed by the Gentiles
right avoiding things strangled drinking
blood you why those none of those things
were for justification they were for the
fellowship with the Saints no but why
Paul so that the church would do rain
one Church the greatest fear odd non
that all of the Apostles had was that
there would be a split in the early
community into a Gentile Christian
Church and a Jewish Christian Church
Paul had great fear of that to be honest
with the every every early movement has
that great fear of a fundamental split
even Islam had the same concern as you
know and so that is his concern that is
Peters concerned that is Paul's concern
and they recognize that if there is not
a concern about having Jewish believers
there's not they're not gonna be able to
have the table fellowship and and the
unity they need to have an integer in a
church but that specific text in acts 15
specifically verifies that the Gentiles
are not to be put under the law to be
able to gain justification they aren't
they do not have to be circumcised they
do not have to enter into that covenant
before they can
the New Covenant there is unity between
Paul and James and Peter right so why
does Paul how does the Unity come about
because Paul simply submits to what no
there is no there is no repeater
verifies what Paul said there is no
rejection on James as part I why would
you read it that way
James when James decided that certain
rules and laws and regulations are to be
followed by the Gentiles not for
justification right I mean it doesn't
say does it say that in the text yeah
because when you look at what the rules
are this they will never have been for
how you made your vows getting hot
is getting heated now I know where I
think you're I've really honestly I've
dealt with Acts chapter 15 but rather in
depth because it is utilized by my Roman
Catholic friends in another context so I
I I've done a lot of work on it and I
don't I really really really honestly
believe I'm gonna challenge you I'm
gonna ask you honestly to to look
carefully at what I did with James
chapter 2 we left James chap I will
definitely do so because I honestly
believe that the reason that Luther said
you quoted Luther yes
you know why Luther said that because
Luther was in a battle for his life with
Roman Catholicism yes and as a result
and you've seen this in the history of
Islam there will be battles that go on
and some people become somewhat
imbalanced because they're fighting
against a particular position you can
and I think must recognize that acts 15
is can is consistent with a proper
reading of James chapter 2 and this
whole idea that you have that there is
this loggerhead between them I know lots
of people who want to introduce problems
in the Bible want to make that argument
there is no reason for it and I don't
think it's consistent for you as a as a
Muslim who has your own book of
Revelation to begin with a
presupposition and examining someone
else's that I can simply take it apart
and make a contradictory to itself one
of the things that I
in my book on the Quran is I attempted
to let the Quran speak for the Quran
first if you allow James and Paul to
speak for themselves first you will
discover that they are friends not
enemies I never claimed there were
enemies in theologically I'm speaking
I'm speaking allegorically there they
are not theological enemies I'm I am
aware of reconciliations or attempted
reconciliations between James and Paul
and I I don't accept them as valid but
you haven't read mine convincing so I
didn't have you read mine I will have to
read your gonna have to read mine that's
right I don't see if it changes my mind
coming coming to another question it is
claimed that Jesus died willingly on the
cross yes and there are some disturbing
passages which I would like to hear your
response on where it simply states that
Jesus was simply not willing to die and
again it goes back to Psalms 91 Psalms
chapter 91 right okay so in the book of
Matthew chapter 21 verse 22 we're told
you will receive whatever you ask for in
prayer right Jesus is basically telling
people that you will receive if you pray
for it you will receive it then we are
told he prayed in the Gospel of Mark
chapter 14 36 father he said everything
is possible for you take this cup from
me right then Luke 22:42 father if you
are willing take this cup from me then
Matthew 26:39
my father if it is possible I'm gonna
write anytime right so go it okay yeah
really very very quickly when Jesus says
if you ask anything he very clearly
makes a part of his teaching this must
be in accordance with God's will he
doesn't simply say to us
[Music]
shut up thank you sorry he does not
simply say you can go and pray for a
Ferrari and I'm automatically you give
it to you it has to be in accordance
with God's will because that makes your
prayer it doesn't you're not forcing God
to do something in the same way in each
one of those texts you just read she
just said not my will but yours be done
right so to really get to the normal
Muslim objection of this as quickly as I
can when you say Jesus did not want to
die what's your what you really need to
understand is what you're seeing in
those words of Jesus is the sinless son
of God this is not a fear of death he
recognizes he is be going to become sin
on the cross you don't believe that
happened that's the only way to explain
it because you believe Jesus was a
prophet now a prophet would not have
mere fear of death so why did Jesus say
these things because he knew he was
going to be made sin upon the cross and
that is how our salvation would take
place okay gentlemen we are now gonna
move into the closing statements dr.
white will close first he has ten
minutes and then mr. Rashid will close
after him then we will go into some
chosen audience questions at that time
once again I thank all of you for being
here braving the cold and the snow and
of course I thank Adnan 15 our flights
you need to thank somebody for surviving
something like that and coming all the
way here indeed I have been very
severely criticized by many for the fact
that I openly profess my respect for and
love for Muslim people such as odd nun I
think Adnan would be the first person to
say that he is not confused about what
James White believes that James white is
not trying to compromise with Islam the
James White is a critic of Islam but
that he recognizes that I criticize
seeking to be fair and honest and
truthful and what I'm saying and I think
that's simply what it means to be a
Christian we serve Him who is the truth
and therefore we have to be truthful and
that means there are some arguments that
we cannot use because some arguments
just aren't all that good this evening
our subject is is the cross necessary
for salvation and I said in my opening I
demonstrated the centrality of the cross
across the New Testament I would argue
for everyone all of the New Testament
writers the fulfillment of the prophetic
stream from Isaiah and from Psalm 22 and
there's so many other places we could
have gone to see that and the to see the
richness from which the apostles drew
their own understanding of those Old
Testament texts which I believe they
received from Jesus through the Ministry
of the Holy Spirit and and and things
like that we saw all of that but then I
closed by stating that really when you
think about it why is the cross
necessary and you've heard awed nod and
I speaking and and we didn't get a
chance to get into this I wanted to get
into some of the hadith I wanted to talk
about the hadith where the man kills 99
people then he kills a 100th person and
yet he's ushered into paradise because
he was going to a city to find out about
repentance and we should have spent some
more time I think talking about how
God's law is fulfilled and the fact from
the Christian perspective atonement is
necessary so that his law is fulfilled
so with God's not just simply saying
well I'm you've killed a hundred people
I'm gonna let you in anyways because
you're one cubit closer to a city you
were going to from the Christian
perspective that simply doesn't make any
sense and then and then right in that
same section and saw a Muslim and that
that hadith actually is one of the
hadith Qudsi I wanted to ask you whether
you gave that more weight and we can't
get into that now but in that same
section in in Sahih Muslim is a our
three hadith that talked about how on
the day of judgment there could be
certain Muslims that who come to
judgment that have a pile of sins and
their sins will be placed upon a Jew or
a Christian it's in the exact same
section who saw him Muslim I don't know
maybe I'd not take the time to comment
as whether he accepts those hadith as
being as being valid or not but there
are so many of the things we could have
been talking about that all come back to
the issue that is found in the thesis
statement which is a little bit
different than arguing about James
chapter two I'll argue about James
chapter two but is the cross necessary
why is it necessary from the Christian
perspective it's because we recognize
the deadness of man in sin and the
darkness of his heart this is not Paul
read Jeremiah spends some serious time
with the Prophet Jeremiah and he will
tell you you cannot trust the heart of
man it is desperately wicked sick it's
desperately wicked and sick and so if
that heart cannot be fundamentally
changed then how can any one of us ever
do sufficient works that could cause us
to stand before a holy God I believe
when the scripture says that nothing
unclean will dwell in his presence
nothing and then I look at Isaiah
chapter 6 and I see that that vision of
Yahweh exalted and sitting upon his
throne and yeah John tells us that was
Jesus but the holiness of God
Illustrated because the the angels
surround the throne and they they say
holy holy holy nothing unclean there is
no going to be grading on a curve and so
I have to ask the question that man that
killed a hundred people how does he
stand before God what righteousness does
he have because not only has he broken
God's law is a mass murder but there's
all these positive things he never did
he has no righteousness he has no
positive righteousness so how is he
going to dwell in the presence of a holy
God the Christian has an answer and I'll
be perfectly honest with you Adnan I've
read the Quran many times I've read all
of Sahih al-bukhari sorry Muslim most of
even kathira
and my conclusion is that the writer of
the Quran the early Muslims did not have
any idea what the book of Hebrews taught
this didn't know there's no references
to it there's no responses to it there's
no rebuttal of it they did not know the
message of the imputed righteousness of
Jesus Christ or if they heard somebody
talking about it they thought that
someone was saying oh you don't have to
worry about what you do somebody else
does everything for you they don't
recognize the nature of the great
exchange now you've had to learn that
because you're a modern Muslim and you
have to interact with Christianity but
in those early early centuries I see no
evidence that there was understanding of
these things it's that great exchange
that answers the question my sin imputed
to him which is why Jesus says take this
cup from me he's not a coward he's not
afraid of death he is going to be made
sin for us he made him to be sin for us
who knew no sin that we might be made
the righteousness of God in him the
great exchange and how can the great
exchange take place how can God justly
look at me knowing my sin knowing the
things that even this day I've left
undone knowing that I have not treated
people the way they should have been
treated knowing that the greatest
commandment love the Lord your God with
all your heart soul mind and strength
and I stand before you today say I have
not done that this day so how am I
supposed to stand before a holy God how
am I supposed to actually pretend that I
have peace with God Romans 5:1 says
therefore haven't been justified by
faith we have peace with God through our
Lord Jesus Christ whereas that peace
come from it's because I am in
possession of a righteousness that is
not my own it's a righteousness of
another because I have been joined to
Jesus Christ and he did love the father
perfectly every day he has a positive
righteousness that is imputed to me
and he is able as the god-man to bear
not only my sins the multitude of them
that there are but the sins of all of
God's elect people and that's why the
cross is absolutely necessary and so
what I say to Adnan what I say to all
the Muslim people for whom God has given
me a love so that I pray for them I
listen to them I hear them I feel badly
when my fellow Christians refused to do
that
but what I say to all of them is this is
the message of the gospel that has been
kept from you because of 40 Arabic words
and I in in the codon and Sura 4:157
you don't have a mediator you don't have
the god man who can stand in the gap you
don't have the one that can give you
that righteousness you have a zeal and I
appreciate that I appreciate this man's
zeal I appreciate his willingness to
come here and to he's sort of you know
in the minority here you might say on
many different levels even though you'll
notice a lot of the Calvinists here have
beards so you actually can sort of sneak
in a little bit better if that way but
he's come to this place and he knows
he's gonna be the minority person
I appreciate that zeal but he knows in
his heart I hope he knows in his heart
that my greatest desire for him is to
come to understand there's unity and
what this Bible says about what Jesus
Christ did and what he did is enough
it's not just simply a tipping your hat
toward God it is casting yourself
completely and totally upon Jesus Christ
and saying if I'm gonna be saved it's
gonna because of what you've done for me
and then recognizing the result of that
in the New Testament is that God wants
to make me more like Christ which means
I'm gonna love God and I'm gonna love
others I'm gonna hate my sin and he's
going to bring all those good works out
of me as a changed person not
add to what Christ has done but because
that's what glorifies him that's the
beautiful message and it's consistent
across the New Testament that's the
message I have for the Muslim people I
hope that in hearing it in dialog you
will be able to hear it with clarity
that is truly my heart's desire thank
you for being here this evening thank
you sir god bless you all thank you dr.
white mr. Rashid has ten minutes for his
closing statements right thank you James
for that passionate ending I would like
to thank all my hosts who have done an
amazing job in receiving me
accommodating me and making my stay very
comfortable especially Michael o Fallon
is that correct pronunciation and his
team Kathy Larry and all the other
brothers who have been working very very
hard to make mistake comfortable they
picked me up from the airport they
waited for three hours nearly outside
and then brought me to the hotel and
made sure that I have a very comfortable
state so I would from the death of my
heart like to thank James as well for
flying in and taking part in this debate
thank you so much everyone thank you
with regards to this discussion I would
like to say that this is to be cherished
it is to be encouraged Muslims and
Christians coming together as brothers
and sisters in humanity to discuss and
talk and share values that are dear to
us and most importantly demonstrate the
beauty beauty of our faiths by talking
to each other respectfully and honoring
each other in front of God so that's
very important a lot of people don't
agree with us a lot of people would like
to spread hatred they would rather throw
accusations and you know promote
mistrust but that's not you're going to
find with myself and dr. James right
we have deep respect for each other in
this regard with regards to the topic I
think it is very clear to myself and to
possibly some of you that Paul was the
man who was responsible for this
atonement theory he was the one who
forwarded this theory he broke away from
the Jewish tradition and the followers
of Jesus Christ as clearly demonstrated
that he was having debates with the
disciples of Jesus Christ who spent a
lot of time with him and don't forget
that the Gospel of Luke is thought to
have been written by a physician of Paul
a man who was a physician to Paul and if
the book of Acts is written by him then
you expect him to be little biased
towards the man he knows and despite
that there are details in the book of
Acts that highlight the tension between
Paul and the disciples of Jesus Christ
discussing the importance of law to an
extent where James is actually insisting
that law must be followed even by the
Gentiles even by the Gentiles and by
this time Jesus has already been
crucified allegedly as the gospel state
he has been crucified the sacrifice has
been done Paul is already preaching this
is the time for Paul to say to the
disciples you know the sacrifice you
believe in it you know about it the
atonement why are they still discussing
the law is the question so I know James
has talked about it I'll talk about the
Islamic solution now James has raised
the question about the man who killed 99
people and then and it ended up killing
100 people and still had forgiveness if
we look at the details the man was on
his way to seek repentance he was
sincerely seeking repentance from this
way he went to a man who made him
hopeless and he ended up killing that
man as well and he died on the way
and in Islam we are taught by the Quran
and we believe the Quran was revealed by
God Almighty and it is a continuation of
the old tradition to be found in the Old
Testament and in the teachings of Jesus
Christ we firmly believe that Prophet
Muhammad was a true Messenger of God who
did not break away from that tradition
rather he confirmed it confirmed it if
we look at the teachings of Prophet
Muhammad and Jesus they were very very
similar in the book of Matthew chapter
19 verse 18 to 19 we are told and Jesus
said you shall not murder telling this
man who asked him about the first
commandment or a way to salvation to
eternal life and his response you shall
not murder you shall not commit adultery
you shall not steal you shall not bear
false witness honor your father and
mother you shall love your neighbor as
yourself similarly prophet muhammad it
is narrated in sahih al-bukhari one of
the most authentic sources of islam his
companion acaba sorry obadah been Samet
narrated that Allah's apostle said while
a group of his companions were around
him like they were disciples around
Jesus Christ and he said to them swear
allegiance to me 4 number one not to
join anything in worship along with
Allah God Almighty not steal not to
commit illegal sexual intercourse which
is adultery not to kill your children
not to accuse an innocent person of
unchastity not to be disobedient in good
deeds so if you look at the similarity
between the teachings
it seems that Muhammad is more like
Jesus than Paul
Jesus is teaching from the law he's
telling one of his followers to follow
the law you will have eternal life
Muhammad is teaching the same law to his
followers that you want to succeed you
want to have success follow the law and
this is exactly what the Quran taught
when you read the book of James or some
passages I quoted in my opening
statement from the Old Testament as well
as the teachings of Jesus Christ this is
what you find but those who believe and
do righteous deeds we shall admit them
to the Gardens under which rivers flow
to dwell therein forever
a Las promise is the truth and whose
words can be truer than those of Allah
allies by the way the same God who was
worshipped by Abraham Moses and Jesus
the word stated allegedly by Jesus
Christ on the cross were allahi allah he
lama sabachthani which is aramaic allahi
allah elohim come from the same root
word a lot of people think Allah is some
alien God invented by Muslims or the
Arabs no Allah is the same God who
issued by the Israelites referred to by
a different name oh not so different if
you look at the root words of the word
Allah he Elohim and Allah you will see
the same root word another verse in the
Quran chapter 5 verse 9 States Allah has
promised those who believe and do
righteous deeds that for them there is
forgiveness and great reward so in other
words when you read the book of James
James is talking about the same things
James was a very close follower of Jesus
Christ
just like Jesus James is saying believe
and do good deeds believe and do good
deeds believe and do good deeds without
good deeds there is no belief this is
what James is saying effectively in his
book and this is exactly what the Quran
is teaching this is exactly what the
Prophet of Islam taught and then we have
the concept of repentance in the Quran
very clearly stated God as we Muslims
believe stated in the Quran chapter 39
verse 53 say all my servants who have
transgressed against themselves by
committing evil deeds and sins despair
not from the mercy of Allah
very verily Allah forgives sins
collectively truly he is oft-forgiving
most-merciful so if you have committed
sins then simply repent and Allah will
forgive God will forgive if you do not
repent you still have a promise of
salvation a lot of people assume and the
thing that the Muslims do not have a
guarantee of salvation they simply do
not know whether they are going to
paradise or whether they will have
eternal life or not as James alluded to
the point in his presentation that we
don't know what's going to happen
the Muslims don't know to the contrary
we have been promised that we will have
salvation so long as we die as Muslims
and it is narrated in the in the book of
Bihari sahil Bukhari which is again the
most authentic book after the Quran
itself in Kitab ulama and the book of
faith and one of the Companions of the
Prophet Muhammad he narrates the Prophet
said whoever said none has the right to
be worshipped but Allah and has in his
heart good faith equal to the weight of
a barley grain will be taken out of hell
and whoever said none has the right to
be worshipped by Allah but Allah and has
in his heart good faith equal to the
weight of a wheat grain will be taken
out of hell and whoever said none has
the right to be worshipped but Allah and
has in his heart good faith equal to the
weight of an atom will be taken out of
hell in other words those who did not
repent and die in a state of sinful
sinfulness and had faith they will
eventually be taken out of Hellfire and
they will have eternal life so we as
Muslims have an absolute guarantee a
promise so long as we die Muslim so long
as we do not apostatize and worship
other gods besides Allah God that was
worshipped by Abraham Moses and Jesus we
will have salvation this is exactly what
Jesus taught this is exactly what the
Old Testament prophet taught prophets
taught this is exactly what the New
Testament
preachers such as James taught and even
in the synoptic Gospels we saw we find
such teachings so ladies and gentlemen
finally to summarize the presentation we
do not need the cross for salvation
because we find plenty of evidence in
the scriptures that the cross is not the
way to salvation rather believing in God
and doing good works and repenting is
the way to salvation that is the way to
eternal life not the cross as taught by
Paul against all the prophets of the Old
Testament and Jesus Christ and Muhammad
thank you so much thank you so much and
God bless you all thank you mr. Rashid
okay now we're going to go into a quick
rapid-fire round in my attempt is to try
to have us finish up by 10 p.m. and
ensure that everybody including staff
can go home for the evening okay each
person that I asked the question of
whether it be dr. white or mr. Rashid
what will happen is that I will ask them
a question they will have one minute to
respond then their opponent will have 30
seconds for a rebuttal okay and then
we'll go to the next one first question
is for dr. white dr. white without the
originals how do we know that the New
Testament what the New Testament
actually says well we didn't have an
opportunity to get into the argument it
was stated that all scholars have given
up on finding the original sax that's
simply not true show up on Friday dr.
Michael Krueger from Reformed
Theological Seminary will be here we'll
be addressing issues like that
the reality is that even unbelieving
scholars recognize that today we're just
tinkering with the text that we have an
incredibly accurate New Testament
manuscript tradition and it just simply
is not true that everyone has given up
on finding what the originals are the
reality is that we're dealing with a
small percentage of the text as far as
variation is concerned and we do
continue to find new manuscripts so the
the reality is we have an embarrassment
of information to be dealing with much
more than in other religions shall we
say but I'm out of time
thank you dr. white thank you dr. white
for that I simply want to ask everyone
to read boost massacres work the text of
the New Testament its reception
corruption and rest restoration the fact
that the title is worded like that shows
you that the the text of the New
Testament was received it was corrupted
and then there is a process of
restoration which is going on to this
day okay this is a question for mr.
Rashid James 2:10 says for whoever shall
keep the whole law and yet stumbles in
one point he is guilty of all the
question is have you kept the whole law
if not how are your sins forgiven since
you are guilty thank you for that
question that's a very good question I
have answered that question in my final
statement that anyone who is not able to
fulfill the law completely or follow the
law completely rather simply has the
promise that you repent you do your best
to follow the law follow the
instructions of God in his profits and
if you slack which you will there's no
doubt that there's no perfection in this
world as clearly acknowledged by God and
his prophets including Prophet Muhammad
in one of the reports he stated that all
the children of Adam are sinners all of
them not because of the original sin
because they are by nature weak they
are tempted the sin and the best of
sinners are those who repent those who
repent because repentance definitely
immediately wipes away your sins this is
how we are taught this is what we
believe in so anyone who fails to follow
certain injunctions can simply repent
and will be forgiven
thank you sir dr. Wayne however
repentance is not a meritorious thing
repentance is a necessary thing but
repentance does not actually provide the
grounds for forgiveness that's why there
was a sacrificial system that pointed
away from itself to a greater
fulfillment and certainly it was the
intention of James to point out that God
does not grade on a curve and that there
needs to be a mechanism whereby the
guilt of that sin is removed that
mechanism is not any longer the the
blood of goats and calves and bulls that
was all pointing forward to the finished
work of Jesus Christ on the cross
question for dr. white why can't God
just forgive us why must he require
Christ's sacrifice central point of this
debate and that is that God's law in
Christianity represents his nature and
his being it is not just simply well I'm
just gonna come up with this form of law
and that because this sort of pleases me
it represents who he is in himself his
holiness is innate to his being and
therefore there is no possibility for
God to simply go well I know that my law
states that this is abhorrent to me but
I'm going to suspend that and forgive
this person without the law being
fulfilled without the penalty of the law
being fulfilled and I'm going to just
simply allow this contradiction to exist
in my nature this is the real issue that
we have here is that that hadith really
introduces for me a substantial
contradiction in the very nature of God
that does not exist in the Old and New
Testaments because of the sacrificial
system in its fulfillment in Jesus
Christ
smooshy I think the question should be
why do we need the sacrifice of a
rightist innocent person
why does God need to kill an innocent
person for to save guilty people
that's injustice it's like James commits
a crime and I take Michael by the hand
and crucify him does it make sense it
doesn't make sense and God doesn't need
to do this this this I mean I don't like
to use this word but this drama because
if Jesus is God he's not actually
suffering because he's God okay it's
Rashid how can God accept an imperfect
man without impinging on his justice how
can God how can God accept an imperfect
man without impinging on his own justice
God has created us and he knows that we
are imperfect
because that's the way he has created us
he knows that he has given us
temptations he has told us what is good
what is bad and he has given us a free
will and God knows that many if not all
will be tempted by the devil and they
will commit bad deeds and for that
reason they will need to repent
otherwise we are all doomed we are all
doomed if there is no repentance if
there is no forgiveness if there is no
mercy
the fact that God is so merciful makes
him even holier in my eyes he's bigger
than simply taking someone innocent and
kill him on the cross
instead of forgiving them simply so the
Old Testament system was a lot better
than what Paul had to tell us simply
repent to God and God will forgive you
it is it is as simple as that
repent and you will be forgiven dr.
white Jesus Christ freely gave himself
it's not the idea you take some innocent
person and unwillingly place them upon
the cross Jesus Christ gave his life
voluntarily upon the cross of Calvary
this was the agreed plan of Father Son
and Holy Spirit from eternity past and
so it's not some in just action it is a
merciful action and since Jesus is the
god man it is the action of God whereby
he provides the solution to the problem
that mankind face
for dr. white if I read first
Corinthians 16:9 and see within myself
that I am guilty of these sins then what
hope will resolution does Christianity
offer
first Corinthians what 6 says 16:9 I
have a feeling it's 6 9 and 10 because I
don't think there is a first Corinthians
6 this is not an infallible infallible
documenting say all right I'm going I'm
going to assume that we're talking about
the text that came up in the discussion
which is 1st Corinthians chapter 6
verses 9 and 10 and the the the list
that is provided there of sins and then
what I pointed out is Paul's statement
is such were some of you but you were
washed you were sanctified you were
justified in G's in the name of Jesus
Christ and the spirit of our God
so the point is that when you are
redeemed by God when you are born again
you are given a new nature you are
indwelt by the Holy Spirit of God and
therefore it is God's work within our
lives to conform us to the image of
Christ that causes us to desire the
things that God would have us to desire
and to do the things that would glorify
him and so it is not to by doing those
things I'm adding to what Christ did but
is that I am acting consistently with
the Spirit of God that he is placed
within me right the times just finishing
what really perplexes me is the fact
that if Jesus died for our sins as Paul
claimed then whatever sins we commit are
paid for it might be a license to simply
go and go on an orgy chapter 6 for that
matter you know you can have your your
beach parties you can go and you know
abuse children you can have you know you
know I don't want to go into the details
grim details people are doing all kind
of things in the world today so if one
believes in the sacrifice then all of
this is paid for
okay this is question four for Adnan
Rashid what saved Abraham his faith
because it faltered or his obedience
because it was imperfect
I believe Abraham was saved simply due
to his obedience to God he believed
primarily first of all he had to believe
and after believing he was very diligent
in following God's teachings and he was
a sincere man and it was because of his
obedience to God he was saved and not
only he was saved his entire progeny was
promised great things in the form of the
Israelite prophets and eventually
Mohammed I believe Mohammed was actually
foretold in very powerful words Isaiah
53 if it's a prophecy about Jesus then
Isaiah 42 is more so about Mohammed for
telling an arabian arabian prophet who
will come with all these qualities
foretold in that particular passage
so if Isaiah 53 is foretelling Jesus
then there's no problem in accepting
Isaiah 42 as a prophecy for Muhammad so
I think Abraham was the cause of all
this that happened in his progeny
Abraham was saved by his faith in the
promise that was given to him in Genesis
chapter 15 of the covenant that God
provided to him it wasn't there was no
merit in his goodness he wasn't the the
most holy man and therefore he was
chosen because he was the most holy man
God was free and choosing him but his
the basis of his salvation the same
basis of all the rest of us faith in the
fulfillment of the promises that Yahweh
provided to him in the Covenant last two
questions for dr. white as a Muslim how
can I be saved that's the question
okay if the question is if you're asking
as a Muslim how can you be saved
believe on the Lord Jesus Christ and you
will be saved not by Jesus who is a mere
prophet not a Jesus who is just one
prophet amongst many prophets but the
Jesus of the New Testament the Lord
Jesus Christ
who himself said he came down from
heaven belief and faith in him is
trusting in him completely casting all
of your sin upon him and trusting that
his sacrifice the fact that he gave His
life and rose again on the third day
that seated at the right hand of the
Father that he is able to save
completely those who flee unto Him for
salvation but editing him down to
someone you're a little bit more
comfortable with Jesus said that was not
a possibility mr. Russia as I turn to
respond yes yeah but you have tried
answered the exact question I I don't
think Jesus was simply a mere prophet
and I don't think he ever died for our
sins I don't think that's true and I
don't think he was God in any shape or
form he if he was God then he didn't do
a good job telling us that he was God he
had plenty of opportunities he had time
to to curse the Pharisees he had time to
curse the tree he had time to talk to
people about things I didn't have time
to just state one sentence I am God
worship me so salvation is through
following the law Jesus followed okay
last question for mr. Rashid in your
presentation you said that mark and
Matthew copy from Luke I believe he used
the word plagiarism would you please
provide evidence for this all scholars
of the New Testament and when I say all
I am very confident that all scholars
believe because there are passages in
Luke in Matthew that have been copied
word by a word for Mark James will
confirm that I hope he will and I'm to
speak there are passages in Matthew and
Luke copied word by word for Mark and of
course Luke and Matthew added more
information and then comes along John
with a lot more information a lot more
interpretation that's why scholars
believed that John has this high
Christology he came
we came up with a lot of ideas that
cannot be found in a synoptic tradition
even conservative scholars like ffs
Bruce and Richard baulkham have clearly
stated that the Gospel of John is a lot
more interpretive and a lot more
extensive in in you know extending on
details than the synoptic tradition so
there is plenty of evidence that these
Gospels took ideas and words from each
other especially mark dr. white the
second okay the assumption being made of
course is what's called literary
dependence I do not believe literary
dependence I'm not sure why Muslims push
this so hard because there's all sorts
of things in the Quran where there are
repetitions of stories that differ from
one another that raises questions as to
why one author would be doing that but
the reality is you have the tradition of
Jesus and it is recorded for us by mark
by Matthew by Luke and by John much
later on it's one consistent tradition
and the consistencies come from the fact
they're teaching one one truth ladies in
general would you please think these two
gentlemen for their time and for this
great debate this evening
[Music]
you
[Music]